hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast proteomics profiling of
post translational modifications in
early drug discovery presented by dr.
matt Stokes dr. Don Kirkpatrick and MS
Lillian Phu I'm Cristina jewel of
laborat and I'll be moderating today's
session today's webinar is brought to
you by lab routes and sponsored by cell
signaling technology for more
information on our sponsor please visit
cell signal comm now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box on the left
side of your screen and click send
button will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
hearing or seeing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
click on the answer a question box and
report your problem today's presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits we have
three presenters for you today taking a
soft way of dr. matt stokes associate
director of proteomics at cell
signalling technology matt currently
leads the proteomics products and
services group providing start-to-finish
proteomics solutions for both academic
and industry clients following Matt will
be dr. Don cook Patrick and Miss Lillian
sue of Genentech Don is associate
director and principal scientist
microchemistry proteomics and lipid
omics at Genentech Don has been a member
of the MPL group at Genentech currently
serving as a principal scientist and
associate director of discovery
proteomics
his group focuses on implementing new
technologies to explore cellular
proteins and post translational
modifications Lillian is senior
scientific researcher MPL at Genentech
lilly and joined Genentech in 2003
during her time at Genentech Lillian has
made important contributions to large
and small molecule drug development
through her math through her use of mass
spectrometry spectrometry proteomics for
more detailed biographies on our
speakers please click on the speaker
biographies tab at the top of your
screen so without further ado dr. Stokes
you may now begin your presentation
thank you
welcome everyone thanks for joining us
today I'm going to give an overview of
the mass spec based proteomics we're
doing here at cell signaling technology
and most of that involves what we call
PTM scan so PTM scan is just a
combination of antibody based
enrichments with mass spec to both
identify and quantify
post-translationally modified peptides
it's a method that was developed here at
CST and we've been doing it for a long
time over 10 years now and really the
key to success in PGM scan are the
antibodies that we're using for that
enrichment so typically when we develop
an antibody we use a single peptide or
part of a protein or even a full protein
here we're showing a phospho peptide we
raise antibodies against that peptide
and then purify and end up with
something that's really nice and
specific for one given protein site well
the antibodies we use for PGM scan are a
little bit different so instead of using
a single peptide as our antigen we're
actually using degenerate peptide
libraries so again here we have a
phospho peptide we have a fossil serine
in the middle and an arginine at minus 3
and those two residues are fixed and
present in every peptide in the library
and then we vary all the amino acids
around it we raise antibodies against
that library of peptides and now what we
end up with our antibodies that are
really exquisitely specific for that
targeted motif in this case are xxxx
phospho s but broadly reactive against a
lot of different primary amino acid
sequences
so we can do this for phosphorylation
motifs we can also do it for other PTMs
like a set elation again using that to
generate peptide library approach so we
then take these specialized antibodies
and use them in the method and its
really pretty flexible with respect to
the types of material you can use as
input so we can do PTM scan on cell
lines tissues plant material whole
organisms microbial samples primary
cells or sorted cells even serum or
plasma one of the first things we do is
take that material and digestive
peptides so everything we're doing is
that peptide level not at the level of
proteins or protein complexes so we take
those peptides we enriched with one or
more of our specialized PTM motif
antibodies we run the mass spec we get
our peptide identifications and then we
do our quantification and data analysis
we have a bunch of different varieties
of PTM scans so we can look at
phosphorylation we can look at tyrosine
serine or threonine and shown on the
left is a Venn diagram we can do the
enrichments using antibodies we can also
use it use metal ions on beads I Mac
enrichment one of the interesting things
that we've seen and others have seen is
that depending on how you enrich with an
antibody or with the metal affinity
beads you actually get different in
complimentary pools of phospho peptides
identified and this is particularly
important for phosphotyrosine so to get
good coverage of the tyrosine
phosphorylation using an antibody step
of course we can go beyond
phosphorylation we can look at sites of
ubiquitination or assimilation and here
we use that same degenerate peptide
library approach to make an antibody
against the dye glycine remnant that's
left behind when you digest proteins
that are ubiquitinated or simulated
to fly see an Isetta Latian
methylation on both lysine and arginine
and for both acetylene methyl this is
obviously going far beyond just the
canonical sights on histone tails we're
identifying thousands and thousands of
sites of cellular a set elation or
methylation using these methods
we can look at sites of caspase cleavage
so peptides that have that
characteristic dxd motif to look at a
pop taught ik program
we can look at other lysine acyl
modifications like sucks in election
propio elation mal inhalation glute
aeration
now we can actually look at signaling
pathways so here the method is the same
you cut two peptides do an antibody
enrichment and run the mass spec the
only difference of the antibodies that
we're using so instead of using a say
fausto tyrosine antibody or a set of
lysine antibody what we've actually done
is made multiplex cocktails of our site
specific antibodies and we've designed
those cocktails to interrogate specific
signaling pathways or protein types like
kinase
proteomics so here there's just no
enrichment step we cut two peptides
clean up those peptides and run them on
the instrument to look at what's
happening to protein levels across cells
Western blotting so in cases when it's
not clear which PTM or motif antibody
you should use for the enrichment we can
take those same antibodies run a series
of Western blots and look for changes in
band patterns band intensities and where
you see those changes that informs you
what the best antibody or antibodies
would be for the follow-up mass spec
analysis we call that kind of view and
then once the PPM scan studies complete
we can also do protein protein
interaction Network analysis and we can
actually map the quantitative data that
we get in ppm scan on to either de novo
generated pathways or pre-made canonical
pathways so as I said at the outset
we've been doing this for a number of
years and one of the things that we do
on the website is actually a catalog
when people have used PTM scan in their
work and published and so this is a list
on the left of a few of the
publication's from 2017 I have one brief
example this was some work that was done
at cell signaling technology a few years
ago looking at tyrosine phosphorylation
in ovarian cancer
profiled a whole bunch of different
ovarian samples and what we found was
that in the subset of those we saw
strong phosphorylation of the receptor
tyrosine kinase and we did some
follow-up work and identified a novel
fusion of alq with FM one and
importantly self carrying that sn1 out
fusion are very sensitive to crizotinib
so here we're showing just tumor growth
over the course of a week the Green Line
is the vehicle control and you see we
get growth over the seven days when we
treat with crows odd nib however you can
see that that growth is almost
completely abrogated
similarly we can look at some western
blots and up in the top right corner we
see strong phosphorylation of that sn1
elk fusion and again that
phosphorylation is abrogated by the
presence of Prasad
and so I'm now going to turn it over to
my colleagues at Genentech who will tell
you a little bit about some of the
fantastic work they've been doing using
PTMs again
you
you
all right hi everybody and thank you for
joining us today
together with lily and foo what I'd like
to do today is to tell you about how
proteomics profiling a post
translational modification played out in
the context of early drug discovery so
just as one slide of background both
Lillian and I are members of an
organization known as G red or Genentech
research and early development and our
goal is to make fundamental scientific
discoveries and then translate those
into therapeutics that provide unique
benefits for patients and these
scientific discoveries span the full
range of therapeutic areas from oncology
and immunology to neurosciences we're
going to tell you about the way that
we're using mass spectrometry as a
technology to impact all of these
different areas now when we think about
the functions that are going on with
themselves one key aspect of
understanding that is to understand the
dynamics of the proteome the proteins
that are present the activities that
they have the locations that they're at
as well as the marks or the post
translational modifications that lie
upon them because in many cases these
are controlling the function as well as
the located location of those proteins
with themselves and ultimately proteins
get turned over by a series of different
pathways some of which we'll tell you
about today now the ability to study
proteins in a cellular environment
environment has advanced rapidly over
the last few decades in large part due
to technology advances particularly in
the area of what we call LC ms/ms or
liquid chromatography and tandem mass
spectrometry and so in a simplified view
you can imagine that we have a mixture
of proteins and we digest those proteins
down into an even more complex mixture
of peptides those peptides peptides then
get separated by reverse phase liquid
chromatography and introduced to a mass
spectrometer through a process known as
electrospray ionisation now these mystic
traumas can now identify thousands and
thousands of these peptides per hour I'm
give us a sense of how abundant they are
relative to one another now one of the
significant advances that's been driving
this area of research over the last few
years is really an increase in our
ability to identify and subsequently
quantify these individual features or
peptides you can see just within our own
group over the last ten years we've seen
a full 50 fold increase in our ability
to identify peptides by this mass
spectrometry proteomics approach owing
largely to advances in two main areas
the efficiency of transmitting ions into
the instrument and into the detectors as
well as the speed at which the
instruments are able to process the ions
identify quantify the signals that come
from them now today what we'd like to do
is to focus on one particular protein
that turns out to be of quite a bit of
interest and this is the protein known
as ubiquitin now ubiquitous is really a
multifunctional cellular tool in all
eukaryotic organisms organisms in fact
it's highly conserved 73 of the city 76
and amino acids are completely variant
across all eukaryotes the ubiquitin
pathway control cell division the
control cell death and effectively every
process in between infect so much so
that about 5% of the human genome or
about a thousand genes encode for
components of the ubiquitin pathway
these ACOTA pathway started by pathogens
it's dysregulated in cancer and diabetes
inflammation and neuro degeneration it's
really at the intersection of many what
normal biology as well as
pathophysiological processes for our
purposes another thing that's quite
important about it is that we believe
ubiquitin serves to mark the active
proteome that is it's an insight into
those proteins
they sell at any moment in time feels
are particularly important I that are
that might be changing
they might be changing their their
function whether it be their location
within the cell their activity or their
stability now while you pick what it is
is a protein it functions in a unique
and interesting way and that is that it
see if itself is actually a post
translational modification of other
proteins it becomes attached to protein
target through the coordinated actions
of the e1 e2 and e3 families of enzyme
typically on lysine residues although it
can also be attached to other residues
including cysteines and the n-terminus
of proteins ubiquitin itself has seven
lysine residues and an M terminus and in
fact each of those can participate in
poly ubiquitin
that take on different structural
configurations these different poly
ubiquitinated confer outcomes at the
level of the tart of the target protein
in many cases degradation by the
proteasome but in other cases changes in
the look in their subcellular location
or the activity that they have with
respect to other proteins that they're
interacting with and of course because
so many of these processes need to be
dynamically regulated cells have a whole
host of enzymes that are responsible for
removing ubiquitin signals and
countering the liquid independent
processes and these are frequently
referred to as doves 14-bit which mesas
now when we when we
of ubiquitin the the c-terminal portion
of ubiquitin is particularly important
and so i want to focus on that in in
this slide here so when we think about
how when we think about how we want to
study Vik whatin nation of we keep
puffing across slides here when we think
about studying ubiquitination of
proteins the key question is where on
the substrate or where on the target is
ubiquitin attached and so if we think
about this theoretically a ubiquitinated
protein is effectively a branch to
protein structure and at the position
where you pick wooden is attached to the
substrate you can see this branch really
begins with the c-terminal dicing of the
bit of the ubiquitin protein now in our
traditional workflows we digest proteins
with trypsin which naturally cuts at the
arginine at the minus three position
liberating this dye glycine remnant and
it's this remnant that can be
effectively captured using the
antibodies that were developed at cell
signaling technologies in fact this
ability to enrich GG peptides is really
open to the ubiquitin field to the kinds
of mechanistic studies that are really
important for us to understand its role
in cellular processes now one of the
first places that we recognize the power
of using K G gene profiling within a
series of studies that we have been
working on over the period of years with
da McCoy blueshifts group particularly
focus on the ia P family of III liquid
and ligases
initially thinking about CI ap 1 and 2
and we were looking at those and working
on those and Larter's we have it had a
nice tool compound of molecule known as
BB 6 this nodes in an ibi AP antagonist
now this antagonist of the IITs actually
functions in a really interesting way
namely that it's actually an inhibitor
by activating it causes the CI a protein
C I a P proteins to ubiquitin 8
themselves and subsequently get degraded
as you can see on the right-hand side of
this slide
so a question we wanted to ask was when
bb6 activates CIT is CIP the only
protein that gets ubiquitinated in
response or are some of the other
proteins in its local vicinity also not
also modified by ubiquitin upon that
transient activation we carried out a
kgg experiment following dv6 treatments
of 5 or 20 minutes I'm carrying carried
along a gemcitabine control for
historical purposes we look in at the
data this is a geyser plot where we're
looking at the log 2 ratio on the x axis
and the p value on the y axis of this DV
6 treatment relative to control and in
the top right corner you can see really
the key message that the BB 6 stimulated
cells showed elevated levels of
ubiquitination very specifically of five
proteins on one of those with CIP one
another was its cognate interactor trap
2 and the other three proteins EPS 15 of
15 receptor and intersection 2 are all
members of The Clapper mediated
endocytosis pathway a pathway that you
might predict to be involved with
down-regulating or regular controlling
the levels of protein such as a TNF
receptor at the cell surface
now when we look in at the the
individual when we when we look at in at
the individual peptides from each of
each of these proteins there was another
interesting interesting observation that
came and that is that many different
sites were being ubiquitinated seem to
be hopping around slides a little bit
many different sites were being
ubiquitinated and moreover that all of
these individual sites of ubiquitination
seem to be responding uniformly to the
treatment going up at five minutes sort
of flattening out at twenty minutes and
effectively showing no response in the
gemcitabine and this was a theme that
played out across a number of projects
during the early years that we were
performing these types of studies now
the IEP pathway wasn't the only one
where we took advantage of kgg profiling
in fact this technology was quite
meaningful and revealing inducible the
coordination of a number of interesting
therapeutic targets protein such as mek
one in the context of mek and pi3 kinase
inhibition also the the estrogen
receptor in the context of cells that
are treated with both a stripe in fact
quite often what we'll see is is
proteins within a pathway being induce
ibly Billiton ated when other components
of the pathway occur themselves being
modulated
now a key question within the ubiquitin
field and many of the biology areas that
impact involves identifying the
substrates of III ubiquitin ligases and
debilitating again enzymes in one area
where we've used kgg profiling to great
lengths is to understand the substrates
of the III ligase Parkin as well as the
D ubiquitin AC USB 30 and this is some
work that's been done I've crossed a
couple of studies that I in close
collaboration with barish Bingle and
others
when we looked in at cells where we had
Park inactivated or where we had Park
inactivated in the context of USP 30
over expression what we saw were a
cluster of substrates they're shown in
the lower left-hand side that were
induce ibly liquidated and where those
individual ubiquitination events were
removed by the USP 30 dub and what's
interesting about all of the ones in res
is that they all reside on the outer
mitochondrial membrane exactly the
location where we know each of these two
proteins to function
now I've shown you a whole series of
studies that have been carried out in
cultured cells but of course these types
of experiments can be equally well done
in tissues under the right circumstances
and for that I want to just show you
some data that was collected in a
Listeria infection model in wild-type
and knockout mice for purposes of this
talk it doesn't not so important which
of the Knockouts it is because they
responded equivalently to the infection
but what I'm showing in the table on the
right hand side are a series of proteins
that showed profound increases or
decreases in the extent of
ubiquitination in the top section you
can see proteins that are effectively
all-or-none ubiquitinated in the in the
patent and pata sites that is an
infected with Listeria for three days
a cluster of proteins in the ubiquitin
pathway regulars of transcription such
as stat one in step three as well as two
poly adp-ribose polymerase Azur parts
now you pick what a nation is going on
in the basal state in cells all the time
and there are many important targets
that are being ubiquitinated as a part
of normal function proteins in the liver
such as cytochrome p450s and you can see
strikingly in the lower half of the of
the table how certain protein such as
the p450s and others have their induced
have their basal ubiquitination
effectively turned off in response to
infection in ways that are quite
interesting with respect to drug
development in the role of p450s often
have in in modulating small molecule
inhibitors now I wanted to take a deep
dive on a couple of projects where we've
seen some really interesting things not
with respect to ubiquitination of
proteins on the whole but rather where
specific sites of ubiquitination turned
out to be particularly important for
regulating biological processes and so
to start that I wanted to just give a
brief reminder of program cell death now
a program cell that happens all the time
it also is an important way that cells
respond to infections as well as other
pathogenic stimuli now in the context of
inducing apoptosis or programmed cell
death that's regulated by caspases for
this talk what I want to do is
and talk about apoptosis is induced by
treating cells with tumor necrosis
factor plus the v v6 molecule that I
showed you a moment ago a combination
that will call T B now this will induce
cap caspase activation and lead cells to
die through apoptosis unless those cells
are treated with the caspase inhibitor
zeebad
now what Ziva does is not prevent cell
death altogether but rather shunts those
cells into a new pathway of cell death
known as necroptosis and so for inducing
Nippert necroptosis we're going to refer
to those cells as having been treated
with tbz that is the combination of TNF
bb6 and disease and so just as a
reminder TNF stimulates determine the
the tumor necrosis factor receptor bb6
functions by inhibiting the IEP III
ubiquitin ligases and zeebad functions
by blocking caspase activation
ultimately shutting cells into the necro
tonic pathway
now ubiquitination turns out to be
particularly important in Multan
multiple different ways within this
particular pathway in one place where we
could see that quite readily was in
studying the Bikila nation through
ubiquitin linkage specific antibodies
these are antibodies that were developed
here Genentech originally by Marisa
Matsumoto and Bishvat Dixit and these
antibodies recognized a number of the
different forms of poly ubiquitinated
jizz and cues including those linked
through lysine 11 lysine 48 by scene 63
and what we call the linear chains or
those linked through Matheny number one
and if you look on the top left hand
side you can see that is the way the way
that they were used in in the context of
these studies is actually through immuno
precipitation followed by western
blotting where the proteins in cells
that were treated with the tbz
combination were I peed with one of the
linkage specific antibodies and then
Western blotted with the substrate
itself then you can see in the context
of RIP kinase 1 that there's
ubiquitination through lysine 11 but
strikingly through lighting 63 as well
as this not binding one or linear chain
and to a lesser extent we can see that
same pattern of behavior with proteins
such as clip-in caspase-8
now working closely with the Bhushan
group we carried out a really complex
experiment looking at each of them at
different arms of this pathway in cells
that were either stimulated with TNF
treated with BB six the combination of
of T and B or this TVV treatment which
should push self down into the neck or
product pathway there were many many
proteins that showed interesting
patterns of behavior but I want to focus
in on RIP kinase one and particularly
this site lysine 115 and turns out that
this lysine 115 site lies in the kinase
domain but just outside of the just
outside of the active site
sometimes group went about making
mutants of RIP kinase one this is a
lysine 115 to arginine mutation and
there's a couple of really interesting
patterns of behavior that we see with
proteins that lack this lysine 115
ubiquitin acceptor site first of those
is on the right hand side you can see
that K 115 are RIF kinase one is note is
not phosphorylated as is the comparable
wild-type protein shown to its left and
moreover we fail to see the high
molecular weight bands or smearing
that's reminiscent of the liquid and
signal that work that we're detecting
with the k GG profile now this these two
events not only exists within whole cell
lysate but also are found in samples
that are immunoprecipitated with
caspase-8 demonstrating their
participation in a larger complex that's
controlling Masanga
regulatory machine
now where the rubber really hits the
road is here and that is that lysine 115
plays an important role in controlling
one of the two cell death pathways and
you can see that on the right hand side
of the slide in cells that have either
wild-type K 115 or mutant or the kinase
dead rip kinase 1 and are treated with
the apoptotic stimulus TV you can see
that each of those different cell groups
undergo cell death through the apoptotic
program it shows the decrease in cell
survival
that's contrasted dramatically with
those cells that are treated with TFB b6
and zeebad the necro product stimulus
those cells that Express wild-type rip
kinase 1 still die whereas those cells
that lack the kinase activity of
replenish 1 or this single lysine 115
ubiquitination site are completely
refractory to this neck rope tonic
stimulus now the rip time is one pathway
turns out not to be the only place where
this pattern of behavior exists in fact
we had a parallel study ongoing looking
at two related family members the RIP
kinase 2 protein as well as the e3
ubiquitin ligase notice Xie P now these
two proteins function downstream of a
receptor known as nod to and not to
recognizes bacterial peptidoglycan known
as muir meal dipeptide now the
traditional signaling is that mule not
to activation by MVP leads to the
generation of protech pro-inflammatory
cytokines and so we wanted to understand
the cross talk between ripped a 2 and
Xie P in the context of in the context
of this signaling pathway
so just as I said showed you before
linkage specific antibodies turn out to
be particularly informative in this case
you can see IP Western blots performed
with the k63 as well as the linear
ubiquitin antibodies reveal robust
simulation of ubiquitination on rips
kinase 2 by MVP and moreover that each
of these can be inhibited by a compound
that's a selective xip antagonist this
is a molecule known as xB 2d 89 you see
a significant attenuation of the
ubiquitination through both of these
linkages as well as an elimination of
the of the phosphorylation on RIF kinase
ripp kinase 2 and downstream targets so
again the question is which which
ubiquitination events are induced
broadly by MDT simulation of the nod to
receptor and which of those can be
specifically inhibited by blocking the
XIT ligase and it was here that we've
got an interesting surprise on the
bottom right-hand side which you can see
is an XY scatter plot or two biological
replicates for cells that were treated
basically comparing the 30-minute time
point with MVP treatment versus that
same treatment in the presence of xip
inhibition and what we saw were a
cluster of ubiquitination sites on route
kinase 2 but those clusters did not
respond similarly on the bottom left you
can see lysine 376 as a representative
example of really the ones in the
cluster at the center a site that was
inducible by MDP and that was refractory
to XIT inhibition on the right hand side
lysine 538 at comparably lysine 4/10 lie
in this lower left-hand quadrant these
are sites that are induce ibly
ubiquitinated in response to MVP
stimulation but are largely attenuated
in cells where X is blocked and that
suggested that these two life scenes had
particularly interesting functional
activities the Richard Boucher group
went on and and generate a series of
mutants including this k1 K for 10k 538
double mutant form of RIP kinase 2 i'm
the western blots on the left again you
can see attenuated ubiquitination
through both K 63 and linear chains
and on the bottom right that riff - - is
not phosphorylated effectively in the
context of this double mutant protein
but most importantly of all what you can
see is that the double mutant K for 10k
5:38 protein does not fully rescue the
cytokine secretion that's induced by
mere mental dipeptide in the presence of
wild-type protein showing a more than 2
fold decrease in that in that cytokine
release
now as we work in the context of these
pathways that control the innate immune
system there is a really important
caveat that we should all be aware of
when we're thinking about kgg profiling
and it plays out in the context of
ubiquitin life proteins such as net 8
and is G 15 now it turns out ubiquitin
and these two family members all have
our G G as the last three residues
within their sequence meaning that when
they are cut with trypsin they generate
peptides that can be recognized and
enriched and captured by this kgg
profiling now you can see in the context
of the Listeria infection data that I
showed you a moment ago that in fact is
G 15 displays elevated levels of D G
peptides on itself in the infection
model and suggesting that some of the
substrates that are being identified
here and potentially in other experiment
might also be coming from is G 15 it was
at this in mind that we were
particularly and interested in some
recent work that came from David
commander's lab looking at a viral
protease that's known to cut is yield to
cut is G off of proteins it turns out
that this protease works in a unique and
interesting way it's the prettiest that
recognizes is G 15 and cuts between the
arginine at the minus 3 position and
this dye glycine terminus that's
attached to the substrate protein in
fact leaving the same dye glycine
remnant that we're fishing out at the
peptide level attached to protein
substrates that it acts upon and so with
this in mind the same kgg antibodies
that we've been using for our
experiments thus far now have a whole
host of new uses potentially in studying
protein isolation in combination with
this interesting new new protease now
the idea of of leveraging leveraging
additional protease and other strategies
to study the ubiquitin like proteins is
in fact an area of active work in many
groups we were quite impressed by some
of the work that came recently from
Betsy coleus and Eric Bennett down at UC
San Diego working close working closely
with colleagues that are part of cell
signaling technologies to take advantage
of a protease that they discovered down
at UCSD known as well P and what they
what they found with Wolpe is that this
protease cut adjacent to threonine
residues and in fact could liberate a GG
peptide from simulated substrate making
those kgg peptides equally well amenable
to kgg enrichment using the technologies
that we've been thus far describing and
talking about in the context of
profiling e-liquid ubiquitination now
with all of this in mind as we start to
try to study and understand pathways
that are controlled by ubiquitin another
ubiquitin like proteins time resolution
is really is really key that these are
dynamic processes working on many
proteins in many sites but in fact
understanding that time domain is is
really important because of course if in
this simple example I told you that
there were three proteins that each
changed by two fold at a three hour time
point the initial assumption might be
that these proteins were all being
equivalently affected by a given by
given stimulus but of course there are
many ways that these time courses can
shape up and really having the granular
a granular understanding of the
time-dependent effects of biological
stimuli is really the key to
understanding the way that that proteins
are ultimately regulating cellular
functions now if we hope to get there
the place that we can see moving is is
toward multiplexing and there has been
some nice work that's been done by Steve
Gees group Chris Rose and others to take
advantage of some of the existing
multiplexing technologies if we want to
do this you know Ruben reproducibly and
thoroughly it'll be ideal for us to come
up with ways that we can prepare and
analyze these samples in a more
efficient way so that we can you know
bring these technologies truly to bear
and it's with that in mind that I want
to handle the mic over to my colleague
Lilian who is going to tell you about
the work that we've been doing to
automate this kdg PTM scan protocol to
really bring the time domain and
multiplexing to fruition
in
dawn says Donna has shown you TGG PTM
scan is a commonly employed workflow in
our lab which we've applied to numerous
projects it's a sample handling
intensive protocol that takes four days
of sample prep before we can inject that
sample on to the mass spectrometer and
in our group the maximum annual capacity
is currently eight to ten samples at any
one time in order to maintain
reproducibility and as we are looking
toward multiplexing automation is really
something that's going to help us
increase throughput and reduce the
amount of hands-on time
you
oh so what I'm showing you here is an
overview of the PTM scan protocol
looking at the steps there were three
steps that were ideally suited for
automation and those were the
large-scale C team set Pak peptide
purification step the immune affinity
enrichment step as well as the small
scale stage tip cleanup step and today
I'm going to tell you about our efforts
towards automating the IEP step of the
ppm scan protocol shown here is the IP
manual protocol on just very briefly
antibody couple beads are integrated
with our digested peptides containing
our kgg peptides of interest the beads
are then washed several times to remove
nonspecific binding prior to elution
with acid you can see it's a fairly
straightforward protocol and you can
imagine if we can transfer the antibody
onto a tip format that would make the
protocol really amenable to automation
and the automation platform that we
settled on was to use by nexuses MEA
system is a great entry level automation
platform it is a 12 channel bench top
system that offers us the flexibility of
working with either 200 microlitre or
thousand micro liter pipette head it's
really streamlined and configurable and
allows us to work with different plate
formats it's easy to operate is Cauldron
compatible which was something that was
really important for us as we have steps
in the protocol that needed to be
performed at 4 degrees Celsius and the
methods that are developed using this
platform are transferable to other
automation platforms if we end up
wanting to move over to an even higher
throughput system so the early
optimization experiments that we
performed on the MVA system we're all
performed using a simple 3 TG peptide
mix which we coupled to Moll DMS as our
quantitative readout and using this
simple platform really enabled us to do
quick experiments to select the
appropriate tip format that we wanted to
move forward with to also study the
effects of temperature on peptide
capture as well as the early experiments
investigating the covalent cross-linking
of the qgg antibody to pushing a resin
in this last point I'll talk about a
little bit later once we had optimized
some conditions using the simple
platform we moved over to looking at
samples that were more representative of
realized samples and to do this quickly
we ended up asking our members in the
group for their left over life States
from their experiments and we ended up
pulling these live states and using that
as our input for the rest of these
experiments and LC ms/ms analysis for
this method development project was all
done on our Orbitrap elite mass spec to
save precious time on
most systems so one of the first
experiments we did was really a
head-to-head comparison of the manual
method in our hands versus the automated
protocol that was developed using these
leftover life aids and the way that we
did this was to go ahead and pack the
STS antibody pre loaded resin into tip
format and put that on to the by Nexus
MEA system and what I'm showing you here
are the results from that experiment on
the left hand side what you'll see
graphed are the number of unique peptide
identifications that came out from the
automated sample prep versus the manual
sample prep and in blue bars are the
number of identifications of kgg
peptides and the red bars are the number
of peptide identification coming from
nonspecific identifications or non caged
peptides and I hope you can appreciate
is that we do get similar numbers of kgg
peptides identified via the manual
protocol and the automated protocol
interestingly if you look at the non jgg
peptides that identify you can see that
there is a higher number that identified
in the manual manually prepared samples
and that's reflected on the right hand
side graph shown where we're applauding
kgg over the non kgg peptide ID ratio so
if we go ahead and look at the
quantitative data coming from these
which are the peptide areas under the
curve you can see again reflected in
quantitative data that the automated
method and the manual method produce
similar recovery of kgg peptides whereas
when you look at the non kgg peptide
signals you can see that the manual
method does yield two fold increase in
signal and we really think that is
reflective of the fact that the
automated processing yields more
efficient washing so we were able to
more completely remove the liquid from
the resonant
each step wears when we're processing
the sample manually it can be difficult
to remove all of the liquid at each step
use resulting in some transfer of liquid
so as I've shown you the manual and the
automated method yield pretty comparable
results but how do they compare in terms
of time reproducibility and capacity in
terms of time the automated method has
resulted in a reduction of about 75% of
manual sample handling time so we've
been able to go down from one to
one-and-a-half hours down to over 15
minutes
in terms of reproducibility the
automated method really allows us to
ensure uniformity as all the samples and
tips process concurrently whereas in the
manual method we can have variability in
sample handling as we are handling each
of the tubes individually and
sequentially in terms of capacity as I
mentioned to you before we're able to
process about eight to ten samples per
one and a half hours hands on time
whereas in the automated platform for
the same amount of hands-on time we were
able to process 60 samples so as a part
of optimizing options for automated
platform we also evaluated the
performance of different protein a
resins that were available to us my
Nexus had two different protein a resins
that were available for use in their
flight format which is the protein a the
pro a protein a resin which features of
standard protein a protein and they also
offer a protein plus line which features
the a recombinant alkali protein a as
coupled to the resin matrix in an
orientation for maximal capacity and
then for this study we also included the
STS pre coupled
she antibody to the resin I wanted to
mention here that we for this experiment
we match the antibody input amounts and
that resulted in the CST antibody being
used at twice the volume as the propyl s
in the probe a shown here are the
results for that experiment looking at
the number of unique peptide
identification I hope you can see is
that we get the highest number of kgg
peptides identified with the lowest
number of non kgg peptides again that's
reflected if you look at the graph on
the right showing the k ug over 9 kg
peptide ID issues and if we look again
at the quantitative data you can see
that we do have the highest recovery of
qgg peptides with ProPlus with the with
little nonspecific binding and so we
decided to go ahead and select the Pro
Plus by tip for our automation platform
as I mentioned earlier we did
investigate the use of JG antibody
covertly cross-linked to protein a resin
for our automated platform and this was
really in an effort to reduce the amount
of antibody that is eluded along with
the peptides when we're using
non-crossing to antibody and this
antibody that saluted can interfere with
downstream mass spec analysis and our
groupie reserves the LC column clogging
as well as a deterioration of
chromatography which is really important
when you're doing label free
quantitation that the chromatography is
consistent from run to run additionally
many groups in this field have published
really highly sensitive protocols
incorporating the use of cross-linked
antibodies in their detection of TGG
peptides
and based on so based on our early
experiments with our simple platform we
chose to go ahead and utilize EDC so for
NHS chemistry for our covalent
crosslinking experiments so EDC is a
zero length cargo tie in my cross linker
that in combination with so for NHS
forms a stable non reversible amide bond
people between carboxylate and primary
amine group I'm showing you here the EDC
soulful NHS reaction scheme whereby a
carboxylic acid is conjugated to an
amide bond to a primary amine
what I'm showing you here is the EDC
soulful NHS cross-linking protocol that
we used to crosslink our antibody onto
the resin so first we incubated our
protein a resin with the antibody then
washed away all the unbound antibody and
then incubated with our EDC so for NHS
reagents what I want to point out here
is that with cross-linking our antibody
as well as protein a are modified and we
really need to evaluate whether or not
our antibody epitope is affected by
introducing this cross-linking so of
course we did SDS page to see to assess
the cross-linking efficiency and when
I'm showing you here is a gel image with
TFA Aleutians loaded you can see for the
EDC so for NHS cross-linked samples we
have very little antibody are coming off
as compared to the non cross-linked
material and when we go ahead and
compare the performance of the non
cross-linked and cross-linked antibody
resins what you can see here again is
that we do get similar numbers of kgg
peptides that are identified in the
cross-linked and non costly
antibody resins but when you go ahead
and compare the number of non TGG
peptides that are densified what you can
appreciate is there is an increase in
the identification of nonspecific
peptides which is about a three-fold
increase and this was something that we
were concerned about since this increase
in Lance's that a bunny can potentially
affect the identification of our target
ktd peptides by competing for instrument
time so we went ahead to investigate
whether or not we could perform a couple
of additional IEP washes to see whether
or not we can reduce the nonspecific
binding this
you can see from the data the amount of
noise that the finding is still
comparable to the samples where we
didn't have the additional washes so if
we go ahead and look at the quantitative
data what you can see is that we do
observed increased peptide signal for
the cross-linked antibody resins for
both the kgg and non kg peptides and you
can see that we see an increase of about
one and a half fold which does not
change with the introduction of the
extra washes and this really suggested
to us that the modification of the kgg
antibody and the protein a with EDC NHS
cross-linking reagent affects the
peptide binding characteristics so to
conclude hope dawn and I have showed you
today that we've been able to apply to
GP TM scan to support many small
molecule drug development projects as
well as basic research we've applied
this technology which has allowed us to
identify disability declination of
therapeutic targets and allowed us to
reveal direct targets of multiple ligase
and of enzymes we've also discussed the
opportunities to repurpose cagey
profiling for other ubiquinone like
proteins and finally we're showing you
how we've transferred the manual PTM and
protocol to an automated platform which
is allowed us to increase throughput and
decrease sample handling and finally
we'd like to acknowledge our colleagues
in the NPL group for all their support
and thank our many collaborators for the
opportunity to present their work today
and with that I think we can hand it
over to
the Q&A session Thank You dr. Stokes dr.
Kirkpatrick and miss sue for your
informative presentations we will now
start the live Q&A of the portion of the
webinar now if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left of your screen well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for okay let's get started
our first question we're going to direct
to Matt Matt can the kgg antibody be
used to study simulation are there
similar reagents I can use to study a
simulation yeah absolutely so John had
some nice slides on this in his part of
the talk but basically if you use an
alternative enzyme alpha lytic protease
which likes to cleave after among other
residues threonine you can generate the
same GG remnant and use that same kgg
remnant antibody that's used for
ubiquitin now to study simulation and
one of the nice things is that that
alpha lytic protease enzyme actually
does not like to cleave at lysines and
arginines so you can really get
complementary data your simulation data
won't be polluted by ubiquitinated
peptides as well it's really one or the
other
thanks Matt I'm going to direct this
next question to dawn and Lillian how
would one differentiate different
protein isoforms that may be present for
some proteins in a given pathway yeah
that's a really great question in fact
we see that pattern of behavior all the
time when one or more isoforms are
expressed within a given cell type at
any moment in time will often see the
quitin ation of both and I think the way
to distinguish them is to look for
peptides that are unique to the
individual sequences of the two proteins
what we often find for members of a
family like that is that in fact it's
the shared sequences that are themselves
modified presumably because the
structural domains are shared in common
and in some cases one can distinguish
them by individual media you know math
amino acid variants and in other cases
the peptides are
indistinguishable it between two
isoforms at which point you can say that
one or the other or both of the two the
two proteins are modified by ubiquitin
thanks Don
I'm gonna hop back over to you Matt how
much starting material do you need to do
a typical PTMs scan fa sure you know it
kind of depends I would say for any
antibody based enrichment you're looking
at ideally you know milligram quantities
of total protein input I will say it
kind of varies by the antibody that
you're using so for example something
like phosphotyrosine where it's more of
a rare mod modification compared to
serine threonine the more material you
can get the better up to you know 10 to
15 milligrams of protein other
modifications like a set of lysine we've
had really nice data from that down to
you know 100 or 200 micrograms of total
protein and you're still seeing hundreds
to thousands of the subtle Asian sites
I'd also say that there are other
options for when quantities of material
are really limiting so total proteomics
can take anywhere from 100 micrograms
down to just a couple micrograms to get
that data and I Mack the metal affinity
enrichment for serine threonine
phosphorylation 1/2 microgram v sorry
500 micrograms is is plenty for that
thank you Matt and we have time for one
more question
dawn in the land I'll send this to your
way what software are you using for the
label-free quantification yeah that's
another good question that comes up
quite a bit so within our group we're
actually running some in-house software
that basically ties together a series of
modules to perform the various steps in
the data analysis process with respect
to the label free quantitation we're
taking advantage of a piece of software
called disick want or cross quant that
was originally published by Cori Vakil
RC and Steve de and a jpr paper back
about 10 years ago and it's been updated
to be able to handle the sort of match
between runs features that some of the
more recent software tools such as max
quant do quite well so there are a
number what number of ways to do it both
publicly available tools as well as
commercial tools and the one that we're
we're using is one that we have had here
in the lab for a period of time
I'll just add to that briefly that we
also do a lot of label frequent and
we've used a few different programs
we've used progenesis skyline which is a
free piece of software has worked well
for us and then I know a lot of users
out there are using Mac's quant and the
max wants to do to do their label free
quantification thank you for those
answers and thank you dr. Stokes dr.
Kirkpatrick and miss sue for your
presentations today would any of you
like to leave our audience with any
final comments
I think I just like this is Matt Stokes
I think I just like to again thank
everybody for for joining on today and
if anybody has any questions that we
didn't get a chance to get to today
we're always happy to talk you can send
an email to PTM scan at cell signal comm
or go on to the website there's a lot of
great information on the proteomics page
at cell signal comm
you
you now before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions I do see
there are a few more questions in the
queue but those questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we'd like to thank
laberd's and our sponsors cell signaling
technology for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through September 2018
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thanks for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon
bye now